okay stream is live here we go
welcome to lecture six
so if you recall from last time uh we
ended
the last lecture hoping to talk about
the chandy lane port snapshot algorithm
and we didn't quite get to it
that was kind of ambitious to hope that
we would fit it in last time with
everything else that we had to talk
about
um so today we're going to come back and
spend the whole time on snapshots
and we're going to talk about this
chandylamport snapshot algorithm in
detail
so let's put up an agenda for today
it's a little bit of uh out of focus
let's see if we can fix that
there okay so today we're going to cover
the chandy lanport snapshot algorithm
and we'll talk about
limitations
and assumptions
that the algorithm makes and also
properties of the snapshots that it
takes
and then at the end we're going to talk
a little bit about
centralized versus decentralized
algorithms
and if we have time
then we'll get to more of your questions
from the start of course survey
we'll see if we get there all right
so last time we kind of set the stage
for talking about uh the chandelier
snapshot algorithm by talking about what
a snapshot is so
just to recap from last time um if you
have some
distributed execution
uh with a bunch of events
let's say that you want to record a
picture
of what happened in the execution
and we talked about uh what kind of
properties you want to have be true
of that picture that you would record
well one thing that you want
is if you have two events a and b
where a happens before b if b
is in the snapshot then a should be also
so in particular like if this is an
execution over here
where the snapshot on process 2
consisted of
of these two events then it had better
be the case that the snapshot on process
includes this event here because this
event happens before these
otherwise your snapshot wouldn't make
sense so this would be an example of a
snapshot that has this property and this
property
is called consistency so
the word consistency gets used um a lot
in distributed systems
um and it's important not to get too
confused because uh
it's got different meanings in different
com in different contexts
but in the context of a snapshot that's
what consistent means
so this would be an example over here of
a snapshot that's consistent and there's
lots of other examples i could draw of
consistent snapshots
and then other examples that i could
draw of snapchats that aren't and we
looked at a few examples of that last
time
okay so how do you actually get a
consistent snapshot
well that brings us to the chandelier
snapshot algorithm which is kind of
granddaddy of
distributed snapshot algorithms
and what's kind of interesting about
this algorithm is that
it dates from 1985 and if you recall
when we talked about vector clocks
earlier
vector clocks didn't really uh
if vector clocks existed in 1985
then they hadn't really been published
or popularized
so chandi and lamport were not aware of
vector clocks at the time
that they invented this algorithm and so
the algorithm doesn't use vector clocks
there are snapshot algorithms that have
been developed since then that do use
vector clocks
uh and some of them have different
properties than the chandelier algorithm
but we're going to look at this
algorithm because
this is like i say it's the it was the
original distributed snapshot algorithm
that kind of inspired
a great deal of other work um
all right so
let's work through an example and while
i'm working through this example i'll
kind of
write down the steps of the algorithm so
here's how to record a snapshot
so the the process of recording a
snapshot can be kicked off
by a process that we can call the
initiator process
so one or more processes
can initiate a snapshot and this one or
more part is interesting
we'll come back to talking about that a
little bit later
um so what does an initiator process do
well the first thing it has to do is it
records its own state
so all the events that have happened on
it
those are its state at that point
it's going to send a special message out
to the other processes and that's called
a marker message
and it's going to send that marker
message out on all of its
outgoing channels so remember the
concept of channel that we talked about
before
so if you have two processes
let's say p1 and p2 and p1 sends a
message to p2
we think of that message as going on a
channel which we can call c12
so recall from from last time that the
naming convention we use for channels
is that uh this first index here is the
identifier of the of the sender and the
other one is the identifier is the
receiver so this
message here passed through channel c1
c12 so the initiator process is going to
send a marker message out
on all its outgoing channels
so if p1 happened to be the initiator it
would send a marker message on channel
c12 there's also a channel c21
and that would be one of its incoming
channels because that's the channel from
process two to process one so it can't
send on its incoming channels it can
only send on its outgoing channels so
that's what happens
so it has to do that before it does
anything else
like before it does any other sends or
receives or anything
and then it's going to start
recording
the messages it receives on all of its
incoming channels
i wrote the initiator process here but
i'm going to change this to an
initiator process because as i said
there could be one or more
so in our example here let's say that p1
is the initiator
and let's say that it starts taking a
snapshot let's say that this is event a
and this is b
let's say that it starts taking a
snapshot a little bit after
a well then it's going to record its
state
like this and then it's going to send
its marker message
um so i'll do that in a different color
and i'll do a wavy line just to
differentiate it
and it only has one outgoing channel it
has its channel uh
to to process two so it's going to send
that marker message over to process two
uh and then it's also going to start
recording on its incoming channel which
is which is channel 2 1.
okay that's it for the initiator process
what happens when somebody receives a
marker message
there are two cases
so we'll say when
[Music]
process
pi receives a marker message
on oops
on channel cki
so again here this is the channel that
goes from the sender in this case
process pk to the process that we're
talking about which is process pi
so there's two cases
if it is the first
marker pi has seen
then pi will do the following
pi records its state
pi will mark
the channel that i got that marker
message on cki
as empty
pi is going to send a marker out now on
every outgoing channel
and now it's going to
start recording incoming messages
on all its incoming channels except for
cki
so the short version of what the process
does
when it receives a marker message and
it's the first one it's ever seen
is it records its own state
and it starts recording incoming
messages
on every channel except the one that
that marker message came in on
here's the other case
otherwise
this is the case where pi has already
seen a marker message
pi will stop recording
on channel cki which is the channel that
it
just got this marker message on
so that's it so in our example
let's say that
let's throw another message in just to
make it a little bit more interesting
so we have this first message and then
let's say let's say we have another one
here
so p1 was the initiator it recorded its
state like we talked about before
and it sent a marker message
and maybe the marker message uh took a
little while to arrive so let's say that
it arrived right here
um somebody tell me what p2 does
at this point
that's right yep
so what was just said was uh so it
records its state
so its state includes events b and c
so it's going to record those
and now what does it have to do
that's right so it only had one incoming
message or one incoming channel right
in this case we only have two processes
so it only had one incoming channel it
was
it was this um this particular channel
here uh c12
so now that channel has been marked as
empty um
and now what does it have to do it has
to send a marker out on all its outgoing
channels
it's only got one outgoing channel and
it's the channel back to p1 so it's
going to send a marker over here
what happens on p1 so
what does p1 do when it gets that marker
message
so to be very clear we use this word
scene here
what does it mean to talk about a marker
that a that a process has seen
well seen in this case means either a
marker that you've sent
or a marker that you've received so
in this case p1 has actually already
seen a marker right because it saw the
marker that it originally sent
it sent one in the first place so we can
say that it did indeed see one
um so this is not in fact the first
marker message
that um that p that p1 has ever seen
because it it
uh because this one over here counts as
one that has seen
uh so we're in the second case and this
case says
pi stops recording on cki so p1
will stop recording on channel c21 which
it was recording on
uh from before that's what the initiator
does it starts recording on its incoming
channels so at this point right here
p1 can stop recording
are we done at this point well p1 took a
snapshot of its state
and it is done recording it was only
recording on one incoming channel
because there only is one incoming
channel
and so it doesn't need to record anymore
it's now stopped recording on that
channel
if you look at p2 it was also
it also didn't have anything to record
on um
or it doesn't have any more channels to
record because
um this starts recording on all incoming
channels except the one that the marker
came in on but there aren't any others
so we're done at this point we have a
snapshot
so we got the state of both processes
and there's nothing left to record
is this a snapshot that's consistent
well we just defined it a second ago but
i'll write it down again
so or i'll just tell you what it means
again so consistent means
that if an event is in the snapshot
then so were all the events that
happened before it
yeah that's right this is a consistent
snapshot
so the algorithm worked in this tiny
example so this is a perfectly good
snapshot
you could also imagine a slightly
different scenario though
imagine if this marker message right
here
had been a little faster to arrive so
this marker message that went from p1 to
p2
imagine if it had showed up right here
then what would the snapshot look like
well then
p2 would have taken its snapshot of its
own state
earlier and so it would have done like
that
and then the returning marker message
would have come along
like this
and that would have been okay too that
would have also been a perfectly legal
snapshot if it just had a and b
so somebody has to question uh uh in
chat about
um like what exactly gets recorded in a
snapshot
so what we're recording are
the events so the events a
and b and c get recorded in this
snapshot or had this marker message come
along earlier we would just record a
and b um
if you're recording in a channel like
recording messages in a channel
um then that's then those are messages
that are being recorded
but the thing that gets circled here is
events
questions about this so far
great question yeah so somebody asked in
this picture which is pretty small so
maybe we should draw a bigger version of
it to illustrate this point better
somebody asked what if p1 got this
return
of a marker message here and it showed
up after d
so that's a great question so let's draw
a bigger version of the picture to talk
about that
so let's suppose that this happened
suppose that p1 was an initiator
and so it took a snapshot say right
there
it sent its marker message over to its
on the on its only outgoing channel
suppose the marker message arrived right
there
then suppose p2 snapshot at its state
and then the question was what if this
marker message
were to do this
that would be
bad because when the marker message
arrives over here on
on p1 p1 has been
uh recording
on its outgoing channel right and so
this message has arrived here
and so at this point
are you supposed to include event d
and that would be bad right it would be
very bad if event d were included in the
snapshot because
that would make the snapshot
inconsistent right because
c over here is not in the snapshot
so why can this not happen
in the chandelier algorithm
it has to do with the behavior of
channels
so does anybody remember from last time
when we talked about channels and how
they work does anybody remember
what we said about the ordering of
messages in a channel
that's right yeah channels have fifo
behavior
and these marker messages just like any
other message
they have to go through channels just
like the regular application messages so
these black messages here that are
these straight black lines i'll call
these application messages because
they're part of the regular application
that's running
and then these
wavy green ones are what i'll call
marker messages
but both kinds of messages have to go
through channels
so this crossover here
of this marker message and this
application message could not happen
right here under chandylan port
because channels are fifo channels have
fifo behavior
which means that you can't have messages
crossing over each other in a channel a
channel is like a one lane road with no
passing
so great question
in fact it's a question that i've used
on exams before uh
so that's why we don't have to worry
about accidentally recording d in the
snapshot
because this marker message here must
arrive
before this message hits
okay other questions
so now i can't use that one on exams
anymore
darn it
yeah of course
yeah so if you go back to our outline of
what the algorithm does
here um when you get a marker message
you record your state so everything that
had happened previously
encompasses your state all the events
that have occurred on that process up to
that point count
as its state
okay so that was a this is this is it
right this is the algorithm but the only
example that we've looked at is this
really really simple
example with two processes and four
events so i would like to work through
a more detailed longer example
with you and so there's a bit of an
anecdote to tell here
um but before i do that i think now
would be a good moment
to do our quiz question so let's do our
quiz for today
and then after that let's come back and
work through
a longer and more detailed snapshot
example
so i'll put up our quiz
oops
yeah we're doing it a little earlier
than usual today but that's because last
time we did it really late so i figure
uh we'll make up for that
all right so let's take a 10 minute
break and see you at
3 58.
two minute warning
all right welcome back
i appreciate those of you who are
sharing what you're having for lunch
all right
so let's work through a more interesting
example of this algorithm
the story here is that this is an
example that i've i've seen
other people use
so i think this example was originally
due as far as i know
to uh professor indy gupta
and so the story here is that when i was
first starting to teach this course two
years ago
i was looking around for what people did
to teach this algorithm
and so i was in search of slides and
other teaching materials for what did
people do when they taught
shandylandport and
i kept noticing that different people's
slides had the same example in them
and i was able to trace it back to this
one
uh person who seems to have been the
original source of the example and
what's really funny about it
is that the example had a typo
and everybody else who was copying and
pasting this example into their slides
also had the typo
so i have fixed the mistake
and so my example hopefully won't have
that mistake
but i can't take the original credit for
coming up with this example
but somehow uh it's a popular enough
example that a lot of people are using
it as a teaching tool
all right so here's our processes we're
going to say we have three of them
and here's our events
and we've got some messages
all right that should do it so here's
the execution that we're trying to
snapshot
let's suppose that p1 is an initiator
and let's say that it initiates the
snapshot right here right after event b
so what does p1 do when it's initiating
this snapshot
somebody tell me
that's right it records its own state
yep and that's right the next thing that
it's going to do is send out a marker
in fact it's going to send more than one
marker
right so what uh what processes does it
have to send markers to well it has to
send markers out on all
of its outgoing channels so it's going
to send markers to p2 and to p3
so let's say that that happens here
let's say that this marker takes a bit
longer to arrive and so let's say that
it hits
process 2 right there
and what else does it have to do what
else does process one have to do when it
initiates the snapshot
somebody just asked uh isn't the only
outgoing channel to p2
at the position right after b well
do you mean that because p2 is the only
process that we've sent a message to so
far well yes process two is the only
other process that that we've sent a
message to so far
but we have outgoing channels to
everybody
so p1 is aware of the other processes in
the system and it has outgoing channels
to all of them and it has incoming
channels from all of them
similarly p2 has outgoing channels and
incoming channels
uh to everybody
and this actually doesn't have anything
to do with um whether the messages are
broadcast messages or not
so these messages are not broadcast
messages as you can see they're just
point-to-point messages
but in order for us to do this algorithm
every process does have to be aware
of all the other processes
okay so process one has to start
recording on its incoming channels
and it has two of them c21 and c31
so i'll just make a note of that here uh
that we're recording on both of those
channels
by the way here's a question for you
how many marker messages is this
algorithm eventually going to have to
send
six yeah that's a good answer um so what
about in general
well everybody's gonna send one to
everybody else
right so process one is going to have to
send one to both of these
process two is gonna have to send one to
both of these process three is gonna
have to send one to both of these
so if everybody has to send one to
everybody else
uh that's gonna be how many if there are
n
processes
it's not n factorial that's a little bit
of an overestimate
yeah that's right so the number of
messages that gets sent
is n times n minus one
that's a lot right
so maybe you don't want to take
snapshots too often
adds a lot of overhead to have to send
all these messages around
so i intentionally made one of these
marker messages slow so that you can see
that the algorithm is still going to
work even if it's going to take a while
for this message to arrive
okay so let's talk about what happens
here p3 gets the marker message
what happens has p3 ever seen a marker
message before
nope that's right so it does what
that's right it's going to record its
own state
and this message landed just a bit
before event j so
j is not included
it had two incoming channels right
process three had incoming channels from
p1 and p2
so it's going to mark the channel c13
as empty so channel c13 was
was one of its two incoming channels and
that one is now going to get marked as
as empty so i'll just uh cross it off
here
to show that it's empty
we still have the other incoming channel
which was c23
so we're still having to record on that
one
so what happens then well now p3 is
going to have to send a marker on its
outgoing channels
so it's got two of them it's got
outgoing channels to
process one and process two
so let's put those in
like that
so now things look like this the marker
message goes out to p1 and p2
let's look here at what's going on on p1
first
this marker messages is it the first
message that
marker message that p1 has seen
no because it originally sent them
so it's not the first marker message
that p1 has seen so what does p1 do
that's right so it's going to stop
recording
on the channel that the marker message
came in on because it's not the first
marker message that it's seen so it's
the otherwise case in that
algorithm that we wrote out before so
channel c31 is done we no longer are
recording on that
it didn't receive any messages on that
channel while it was recording anyway
so now the the state of that channel is
is
is no longer no longer recording and the
state of that channel is empty
all right now we can look at this marker
message that went from
p3 to p2
what does p2 do when it gets this marker
message is it the first marker message
that p2 has seen
that's right it is okay so what does p2
have to do
that's right yeah it records its state
so that's going to involve all these
events here
it's going to mark the state of the
channel that the marker arrived on as
empty
so it had two incoming channels
um from from p1 and p3
um it's gonna it's gonna mark the state
of
of um the incoming
channel uh c32
as empty
it also had another incoming channel c12
and now it has to send out its own
marker messages on its outgoing channels
to the other two processes
so those marker messages are going to go
out
something like that
so here we are all of the marker
messages that need to get sent have been
sent
all of the channels have recorded our
their state
so how is it looking down here with
these uh with these channels that we're
we're recording on well
process one marked channel c three one
is empty it's no longer recording there
um process two marked channel c three
two the channel from process 3 is empty
process 3 marks channel c13 as empty
now the marker message that p1 sent way
back when is finally going to get here
to p2
so what's the deal on p2 right now has
p2 already seen a marker message
ah somebody just pointed out that i kind
of drew this poorly here
so i should have drawn this circle
uh differently so the the
marker message arrived at p2 right here
and so this circle should have been like
this
because the snapshot happened at the
point when this marker message was
received and then these two messages
here that p2 sends out they should have
been a little bit lower
so thanks for pointing that out
so i can try to fix it here
yeah so when this marker message here
finally arrives at p2
after maybe a delay p2 has already seen
a marker message at that point
so what does p2 do
well because p2 has already seen a
marker
it can now stop recording on the channel
that that marker message came in on
so i can cross that off here
and no messages were received on that
channel so that's that's going to be an
empty one as well
so now p2's job is done it's recorded
its own state
and it's done recording on both of its
channels
so p2 is all set
p1 over here still needs to finish up um
so it still had this channel that it was
recording on channel two one
so it was waiting for a marker to come
in from
process two so that it could stop
recording on channel two one and look
there's that marker that just came in
so this is kind of an interesting case
because
when you record on a channel you should
be keeping
track of messages that you received on
that channel
and it turned out that one message did
come in during the time that we were
recording
on that incoming channel so if you look
at this whole
chunk of time right here from between
when we started recording
and right here when we stopped recording
we did indeed receive a message right
here i'll call it m1
so a message got recorded
on channel 2 1 the message he'd send was
event h and whose uh
receive was event d um so we can make a
note of that actually
and now we're done recording on channel
two one there's nothing else to do there
and what about over here finally process
three gets the last marker that it was
waiting for
it was waiting for a marker um
from process two
and it can set the final state of this
channel to empty because no messages
came in during the time that it was
recording
so now everybody's done everybody has
recorded their process state
uh and we also captured that this
message got sent
during this time um so that's kind of
interesting right
so we've got all these um
process states which consist of sets of
events
and then we have this extra piece of
information which is that a message got
sent
uh from process two to process one which
is captured in the state of this channel
c21
so we're done nobody is still recording
on any channels
and the snapshot consists of
these events that we've circled up here
plus because uh chandy lamport also
records on channels we have this
additional piece of information which is
like oh by the way also this message got
sent
but you don't necessarily have to think
of that as part of the snapshot the
snapshot is really just
these events
okay so if we look at this snapshot
does it look like a consistent snapshot
well
recall that a consistent snapshot means
that if an event is in the snapshot
then so is everything that that happened
before that event
so we can kind of glance at it and see
like if if we look at h here for example
well what happened before h well g did
and f did for sure
and then we can see that i did as well
and then up here we can see following
arrows that
b and a also happened before h
so it looks like this is a consistent
snapshot and if we wanted to
we could draw a sort of line across this
whole diagram
and it's going to be a little awkward
because j here isn't included in the
snapshot so the line is going to have to
kind of go in between here
but we could draw a line right here
that kind of divides this um this
execution
into two pieces
so this past piece over here i'll call
this past
and i'll call this future
so the snapshot captures everything that
happened in the past
and it would be really bad if there were
any events that were captured in this
past piece over here um
that had um events that were in their
causal history
right that weren't in the snapshot but
we know that that's not going to happen
because one of the guarantees that the
chandelier port algorithm gives us is
that snapshots will be consistent
all right i know that was a pretty hairy
example
but that's my walkthrough of the
chandelier port algorithm
any questions about that and then i'm
going to talk a little bit about the big
picture of
all this and some properties of the
of the snapshot that we recorded and
assumptions that this algorithm makes
ah okay the question is uh what is sent
in a marker message
so the marker message doesn't really
have any content other than
i'm a marker message so
the marker message doesn't have to
contain anything it doesn't have to have
any contents other than i'm a marker
message because
the behavior of the algorithm doesn't
depend on the contents of the message
it's just um is the message a marker
message or not
another question in chat does a
or does p1 first record its state
after after event b yeah so we were
saying here that
this point right here happens to be when
p1 initiates the snapshot now
p1 could have initiated the snapshot
earlier if it had initiated the snapshot
earlier then our
then our snapshot would look different
but yeah in this particular example the
point at which p1 recorded at state we
were saying happens after event b
other questions
okay one question is does p1 have to be
the initiator no
so not only could somebody else have
initiated
but it there could have been more than
one initiator however
if you had a different initiator
you might end up with a different
looking snapshot
but one person says it seems like h
shouldn't be in the snapshot
so
why is that well it would have also been
a legal snapshot
to draw the line uh i think it yeah it
would have also been a legal snapshot
had we done this
i think so yeah that looks that looks
okay to me
so why did it happen there uh why why
why did we take the snapshot after h
it's because this marker message that
got sent from from
p3 to p2 happened to land after h
but having the snapshot here doesn't
make it inconsistent
it's just that the snapshot got taken a
little bit later so either one would
have been a legal snapshot
okay another great question what if we
had two different initiators what if two
processes started the snapshot at the
same time
well that would mean that
those processes would each record their
own state right
and then they would start sending out
marker messages so let's say that p1
p3 both decided to start a snapshot um
so let's say that p1 decided to start a
snapshot right here like we said before
and let's say the p3 decided to start a
snapshot now
maybe it started its snapshot a little
bit earlier so
maybe it started snapshot
at this point right here
well then the snapshot of p3 state would
look
it would actually look the same right
because um this circle here doesn't
include any other events
so it would be drawn a little bit
differently but it would be the same set
of events
because jay wasn't in the snapshot
before and it's still not
but then it might mean that p3 would
then send out its marker
messages a little bit earlier right
because then
p3 wouldn't be waiting all the way until
it got a marker message it would be
going ahead and sending out
its marker messages earlier and in fact
had that happened
then maybe h wouldn't be in the snapshot
because maybe p3's marker message would
get to p2 sooner
so you would still end up with a
snapshot that was legal it turns out one
of the really beautiful things about
this algorithm is that
even if you have multiple initiators the
snapshot that you end up with is still a
consistent snapshot
interesting question here so somebody
asked so a snapshot is not the same as
one moment in time
well that's the thing about distributed
systems
there's not really such a thing as one
moment in time
there's no such thing as a global clock
right
so our task is to try to
get everybody to independently record
their state
in a way such that when you stitch all
those pieces together later
you get something that's that makes
sense right
that doesn't uh include any causal
weirdness
and the definition for that is the
definition of a consistent snapshot that
we talked about before
so there's not really such a thing as
having one moment in time across all
these processes the best that we can do
is have different different processes
individually take a snapshot of their
own state
and then manage that state
and manage the point at which those
individual
process snapshots are taken through the
use of these marker messages that the
algorithm
uses
and here's one more question uh from
chat somebody asks
how would p1 and p2 know their channel
is currently in use
i'm not really sure what it means to say
a channel is in use
but maybe what you mean is
how do you know if you're recording on a
channel well
certainly as soon as you snapshot your
own state part of the algorithm is you
start recording on all
all of your incoming channels um
unless you started recording because you
received a marker message
in which case you start recording on all
of your incoming channels except the one
that you got that marker on
so i'm not really sure what it means to
say a channel is in use
but um
maybe the question is whether you're
recording on a on a channel or not in
that case
you start recording and then later on
when you get another marker message
from a given process you you stop
recording on the channel
from that process
so i really like this question about
like does a snapshot represent one
moment in time or not and that actually
reminds me of a quote that i would like
to share so
this is from the original paper about
the chandelier import algorithm
which as we talked about before came out
in 1985 so there's this really beautiful
paragraph from this paper that i love
that i want to share with you so the
authors write
they say the state detection algorithm
and that's their algorithm the algorithm
that they're talking about that they've
invented
the state detection algorithm plays the
role of a group of photographers
observing a panoramic dynamic scene such
as a sky filled with migrating birds
a scene so vast that it cannot be
captured by a single photograph
the photographers must take several
snapshots and piece the snapshots
together to form a picture of the
overall scene
the snapshots cannot all be taken at
precisely the same instant because of
synchronization problems
furthermore the photographers should not
disturb the process
that is being photographed for instance
they cannot get all the birds in the
heavens to remain motionless while the
photographs are taken
yet the composite picture should be
meaningful the problem before us is to
define meaningful and then to determine
how the photographs should be taken
so i really like this analogy a lot
because this is exactly the situation
that we have
where we have to take snapshots of all
these processes
and we can't use clocks we can't use
time of day clocks
because of synchronization problems as
the quote said
and furthermore while we're operating
here while we're sending all these
marker messages around
the application messages which you can
think of as the birds in this analogy
are continuing to happen so
we what we don't want is to say okay
everybody stop sending your application
messages
and hold still so that we can take a
snapshot that would work
you know if we could tell everybody to
hold still
and then take a snapshot we we could do
that but that's
really undesirable
because then our algorithms would be
slow right presumably these messages are
messages that we actually care about and
would like to have
sent sooner rather than later so telling
everybody to stop
while we take the snapshot is rather
undesirable so the one of the really
cool things about this algorithm
is that it can run while these
application messages are still happening
all right so we've just spent a bunch of
time kind of on the gory details of this
particular example
and now i want to talk a little bit
about
the big picture in the time that we have
remaining
so
actually let's call this specifically
chandylan port snapshots
because i'm not talking about every
snapshot algorithm that exists
just this one
so we had to introduce this concept of
channels
in order to explain this algorithm and a
channel
like we said it's a connection from one
process to another and it can be thought
of as a
um it's not it's not necessarily
something that uh
physically exists um but it's a
it's an abstraction um so normally like
when we draw lanport diagrams
there's not anything that we do to say
that one process is connected to another
right we just kind of assume that they
are
so if i draw a lan port diagram and i
have some processes
we just sort of assume that
these processes can send messages to one
another
and that these messages can go back and
forth between all these processes
however they want and we don't have an
explicit
word for the thing that they travel
through
but in this system model that we use for
talking about the chandelier port
algorithm
we did give an explicit name to that
thing and that name is channel
and not only that but channels impose a
limitation on how messages travel
through them
so in particular channels uh have fifo
behavior
so if process one were to send two
messages
then you know that that channel from c
uh um from process1 to process2 channel
c12
um you know that those messages are
going to arrive
in the order sent so
maybe these messages are in flight and
they haven't arrived yet
so they're in the channel at this point
and you know that they're going to be
m1 and then m2 so a channel is a
sequence and messages are going to
travel through it in this fifo fashion
that's what a channel is well it turns
out this assumption that messages get
delivered in this fifo order has to
be in place in order for the chandelier
port algorithm to work
so
we just saw that a little while ago
so if you have a setting where fifo
anomalies can happen
if you have a setting where messages can
uh be delivered out of fifa order
uh you're not satisfying the
prerequisites to run this algorithm
and there actually do exist snapshot
algorithms that don't
assume fifo channels but those those
algorithms have other drawbacks
and in particular my understanding from
the literature on this although i'm not
an expert on snapshots is that
if you want to allow non-fifo channels
then you have to pause application
messages sometimes
so we said that one of the really cool
things about the chandelier algorithm is
that
you don't have to do that
so this is a really interesting
trade-off i think you never need to
pause the application messages in
shandylandport
but you do have to have fifo
and a different snapshot algorithm might
choose a different trade-off
do you think are some other requirements
that have to be in place in order for
the chandelier algorithm to work
aside from this fifo assumption what are
some other
things that the chandelier import
algorithm will assume
what do you think
great guaranteed delivery yeah
the chandylan port algorithm assumes
that messages aren't lost
or corrupted or duplicated
and it also assumes that processes don't
crash
i'm running out of room here
so you might wonder if this is kind of a
crappy distributed algorithm right
because if it doesn't hold up to things
like
messages being lost or processes
crashing
well i guess in its defense
it was the first distributed snapshot
algorithm and it was
groundbreaking at the time and a cool
thing about it
is that it doesn't require pausing of
application messages and
it still works even if messages are
delayed arbitrarily long
as long as they arrive eventually
it'll work so that's a pretty big deal
so these are some assumptions that the
chandylan port algorithm makes
so these are in other words these are
requirements in order for this algorithm
to work correctly
or if you like you could call them
limitations of the algorithm
it assumes that messages aren't lost or
corrupted or duplicated it assumes that
processes don't crash
and it assumes that channels have this
fifo behavior
okay so that things aren't all doom and
gloom
let's talk about some good things about
this algorithm
we already talked about one
which is that snapshots it takes are
consistent
and so to just refresh your memory about
the meaning of that it means that
uh for all uh events
a and b
if a happens before b
and b is in the snapshot
so is a so that's one good thing
anything else that's good here well
what about termination do you think that
the chandi land port algorithm is
guaranteed
to terminate
well so what does it have to do
let's go back to our picture here
it's got to record the state of every
process
and it's got to record the state of
every channel
so if you're a process pick any process
let's say your p3
what parts of the global snapshot are
you responsible for you've got to record
your own state
and then you also have to record on both
of your incoming channels in this
picture you just have the two
so if this terminates
for you if you're if you record your own
state and you record the state of both
your channels then you're done
so do we know that a process can take
care of its own piece of the snapshot
well
recording its own state is pretty easy
right remember
we're assuming that messages arrive
right we're assuming that messages don't
get lost
and we're assuming the processes don't
crash so given those things
sooner or later every process should
receive
a marker right so remember that the
short version of the algorithm is
that when you get your first marker
message that's when you record your own
state
and that's the point also when you start
recording incoming messages so
assuming that stuff that we said a
little while ago about how processes
don't crash and messages are reliably
delivered
you should be in good shape right sooner
or later you're going to receive a
marker message
and then you're going to record your
piece of the state
and then you're done with that piece of
your job
the other piece is that you have to make
sure to finish recording on all of your
incoming channels
so when are you done with that piece how
do you know when it's okay to stop
recording on a channel
that's right after you receive a marker
from that channel so when you receive a
marker on a channel
that's when it's okay to stop recording
on it so basically
once everybody has received a marker on
all of their incoming channels we're
done
and do we know that that happens well
yeah because
the algorithm has a process send out a
marker on all of its outgoing channels
and so one processes outgoing channel is
somebody else's incoming channel
and we've got this assumption of
reliable delivery so that's my
informal argument for why the chandelier
algorithm terminates
every process has its piece of the job
to get done
and i've given you an informal argument
why that particular process is piece of
the job we'll be able to get done
and once everybody independently does
their piece we're done
so i can add that to our list of good
things here
i'll say guaranteed determinate given
assumptions from before
about messages not being lost etc
okay we're not actually going to do a
proof that the algorithm terminates
but if you're unconvinced then i
encourage you to think about it a little
bit on your
own so there's one really cool thing
about this algorithm that i would
like to just dwell on a little bit more
so we said that
it would be fine if more than one
process initiates
so this is really fascinating what if
multiple processes said at the same time
okay i'm going to start taking a
snapshot it turns out that that's okay
the algorithm actually works fine with
multiple initiators
so let's look at a little example of
that
let's say that we have a p1 and p2
and let's say they both decide to
initiate a snapshot at the same time
so let's say that we have events a and b
over here
let's say that we have something like
this
let's look at what happens
so let's suppose that p2 decides to
initiate a snapshot right here
right after b
and independently p2 decides to initiate
a snapshot right after
c like this
well what do you do after you initiate a
snapshot well then you have to send
markers
right they have to send markers to each
other
so p1 is going to send its marker over
like that
and p2 is going to send its marker
my diagram is a little bit crowded here
but hopefully you get the idea
so notice that in particular um
p2 has to send its marker before it does
anything else
so p2 takes a snapshot of its own state
and then it immediately
sends it a marker so notice that it has
to send its marker out before event d
can happen before that can happen the
marker has to go up
so this works fine when they send out
their markers they both start recording
their incoming messages right
um so now p2
um over here is going to record this
incoming message right here let's call
it m1
that went from b to d um
so its channel right here
is going to end up with m1 in it
they get each other's markers and then
they stopped recording so
p1 was also recording on channel c21 but
it didn't have anything to record
because there were no messages received
on that channel so it doesn't have
anything to record there
so c21 that channel its state ended up
empty
everybody finished recording their
channels and everybody took a snapshot
of their state and we have a complete
snapshot
and it's a correct snapshot it it uh
it's consistent
and there's no way that we could have
ended up with an inconsistent snapshot
in this picture
uh if they both initiated the snapshot
so think about what a what an
inconsistent snapshot might look like
well
if d were included like let's say that
let's say we had something like this
if we just had a here and we had a
message like this
and we had c and d here that would be an
inconsistent snapshot as we've talked
about
because we have this event b here which
happened before d
and it's not being included here but
this couldn't happen
because
after p1 takes its snapshot here it has
to send its marker message
over before it does anything else
and that marker message because of fifo
it's going to have to arrive before that
event d so this particular snapshot
wouldn't happen regardless of whether
p2 already snapshotted its state or not
so this is really really cool this
business of working fine with more than
one initiator
this is actually a very big deal why is
it such a big deal
why do you think it's such a big deal
that multiple processes can initiate
this algorithm and it'll still work
yeah no central control yeah
so what if this wasn't true if it wasn't
true
that this algorithm worked fine with
more than one initiator
let's say that i wanted to take a
snapshot right well
what would i have to do well first i
would have to make sure that nobody else
was taking one
right so i would have to go around to
all the other processes i would have to
send them messages and say hey
i'm going to take a snapshot is that
okay with you
and what if you know well i'm waiting to
hear back from everybody what if i get a
message from somebody else saying
hey i'm gonna take a snapshot right well
then i have to
give up on my wanting to take a snapshot
or i'll have to send them a message
saying no
stop so then things get really chaotic
right if anybody wants to take a
snapshot they have to first
clear it with everybody else and say
everybody else stop don't take any
snapshots it's my turn now i have
the lock so
that can cause a lot of problems it can
cause a lot of slowness
and it can cause a lot of chaos if you
don't implement it correctly
so if it's not okay for multiple
processes to initiate then the processes
need a way of deciding who will initiate
and that in and of itself is a really
hard problem in distributed systems
which we're going to talk about in the
second half of this course
but because this algorithm works fine
with multiple initiators
we don't have to worry about any of that
nonsense
so this is really cool so processes do
not have to agree on who we'll initiate
instead if somebody wants to initiate a
snapshot they just go ahead and do it
if somebody else happened to also
initiate one
then maybe they'll receive a marker
message from that other process but
that's fine
it turns out the algorithm still works
if more than one initiates it's not a
problem
so there's a name for algorithms that
have this property
and it's decentralized
we're going to look at a couple examples
of decentralized algorithms in this
class so
shandy lampport is our first example
and another different example that we're
going to talk about later in the course
is paxos
which we haven't talked about at all yet
but we'll get to that in the second half
of the course
so the chandelier algorithm is just is a
decentralized algorithm
not every distributed algorithm is
so but this one is so decentralized
algorithms design
is often really interesting and
they have to be designed in this really
interesting defensive sort of way
that's going to seem strange to people
who are not used to it
because they have to be designed to deal
with this possible case of more than one
initiator
so the design of decentralized
algorithms i think is really interesting
and if if the chandelier port algorithm
looks weird to you
maybe this is the first truly
decentralized algorithm that you've
worked with
that could be why
so by contrast a centralized algorithm
this could still be a distributed
algorithm
but a centralized algorithm
must be initiated by exactly one process
questions about that
all right so the very last thing i want
to talk about and i think we're
because i spent so much time on this is
we're not going to have time to talk
about
responses to the start of course survey
today so that's too bad but
um one last thing i want to say
i want to talk about what snapshots are
for
because we've gone to all this effort to
talk about this algorithm for taking
snapshots
and we've bothered to use a
decentralized algorithm even
but what's the point what can you do
with a snapshot so here's some ideas
checkpointing
so we talked about this on day one of
class right some systems have to take
periodic snapshots of their state
so that if they fail and have to restart
they have a reasonable place to start
from instead of having to start from
scratch
so a snapshot algorithm could be used
for this
here's something else
deadlock detection
so being deadlocked what if your system
is deadlocked well that means one
process is waiting for another
that's actually a bad way to draw it
it's not really a
lan port diagram you just have like
two processes like this and this is our
weights for graph here where process one
is waiting for process two but process
two is waiting for process one
sad state of affairs deadlocks are one
are the state of being deadlocked is a
property where once
it's true at one time it's going to be
true from that point onward as long as
the system is running
so you can check for deadlocks by taking
a snapshot
and then seeing if there's a deadlock in
the snapshot
so if you find a deadlock in your
snapshot then
that's a way to know that your system is
still currently deadlocked because if
there was a deadlock then
even though more messages might have
happened since then it's still there's
still going to be a deadlock
and then more broadly detection
whoops
of any what's called a stable property
and i know we're out of time so i'll
just talk about this briefly
so a stable property is a property that
once it becomes true it stays true
so a deadlock is actually the state of
being deadlocked is actually
an example of that but it turns out that
snapshots can be good for detecting any
stable property
you take a snapshot you see if the
property is true in the snapshot and
then
you know it's still going to be true in
whatever the current state of the system
is
so snapshots are really really useful
for checkpointing and for detecting
certain properties which count as which
are what we call stable properties
and deadlock detection is a common
example of that all right we're out of
time for today
so let's conclude
and i will see you next week